i think it's preposterous that i get to
talk to you guys about uh magruber so
this is a [ __ ] great day
awesome man good to hear i i think it's
preposterous that we got to make another
continuation of this story i never
thought it would have happened
really
honest to god i watched all the episodes
yesterday i did a crazy binge and i i
was sitting here tackling to myself you
know there's so much they're so funny i
i wish i could have seen them with a
crowd but i want to start this interview
off with a huge thank you to peacock
because i just want to thank them for
making this show
it's really sincere a real thank you
that's awesome dude that's really cool
um so uh for both of you guys before i
jump into mcgruber if someone has
actually never seen anything that you've
done before i
if they haven't what's the first thing
you want them watching and why
oh gosh um
it's gonna have to
it's either gonna be magruber young rock
is what i would say because because it's
great to laugh it's funny to laugh um
depending on how i would like stereotype
that type of humor would be which one i
would recommend you know
their family i would say young rock
there you know one of the bros yo
mcgruber that's what you want to
all right watch for me uh
you know i um two two of my favorite
things that i've done i i really you
know loved cruel intentions and
obviously that's kind of like uh stayed
a favorite for a lot of people for a
long time um and i enjoyed the the movie
way of the gun a lot i thought it was
very cool um but
um
the series i did recently shooter was
also something i was really proud of and
i worked really hard on and i was
super physical in that show and so i
think that's kind of a cool one because
i did so much stunt work and action
for both of you guys which of your
friends and family were the most excited
that you were going to be doing
more episodes of magruber or new
episodes of mcgruber
well i have a ton of friends in comedy
um and so
they've been asking me over the years
through text or dm you know is there is
it going to happen is there going to be
another one is there going to be a
sequel so
man i've got about
50 plus people in my life that i cannot
wait for this show to start streaming
yeah many people in my circle like
family they've never heard of mackerel
um
but once i was like i'm gonna be working
with lawrence fishburne they were like
oh my god of course
so that was that was kind of the thing
that really set them off
one of the things about mcgruber is that
it really is the the the show the the
movie the this series it's unlike
anything else out there and i can't
imagine what it's like reading these
scripts for the first time because
they're bananas you know um so can you
can you both talk about what your
reaction reading these scripts um and
you know what you took away from it
yeah i mean for me obviously having been
a part of the first one i had a little
bit of a sense of what to expect but i
didn't know where they were gonna go
with the story in regards to the
aftermath uh from the film and and that
was exciting for me to to watch that
develop as i read each episode but man
um
i left so hard from page one page two of
the very first script and it stayed that
way throughout all eight uh these guys
work so hard on the writing and they
really go over and over and over until
they get it down to the best and
funniest stuff and um it's so my sense
of humor and
um i'm just a fan too so as much as i'm
a part of this show i i i feel like a
fan a lot of times on set around kristen
will and watching them work
yeah i readings i was just laughing i
was it was a lot of laughing it was a
lot of can we say that can you do that
and um
yeah like i'm as well a fan that once i
saw the movie i was like this is
definitely
my wheelhouse this is hilarious
uh i also want to point out for people
that are watching this that the show is
definitely r-rated um in terms of you
know it's like a hard r yeah
it is yes hard r is exactly correct um
for both of you what do you want to
tease people about these upcoming uh
eight episodes um you know it's it's a
lot of what fans of the movie will
expect i think it's very consistent in
tone and feel and and
like you said uh you know the the the
raunchiness of the humor at times um but
you know after the period that we've all
come out of socially and from a life
standpoint of things being so dark and
heavy and everybody being so sensitive
and at each other's throats it's like
it's fun to just check out for a bit and
laugh with a character to whom the rules
don't apply and just somebody who is
like you know
funny to say but like an iconoclast you
know mcgruber is the anti-hero and he
says and does things that none of us
could ever get away with and i think
there's some kind of vicarious
liberation in that
yeah ryan said her best to just expect a
lot a lot of laughs a lot of laughter a
lot of like oh really like yeah
that's that's what they're gonna get
the thing that i'm always surprised that
i was very surprised about with these
eight episodes is that will is one of
the writers and yet he's writing himself
naked into like every possible scene and
i'm like the whole show i mean i just
couldn't believe what i'm watching so
what but that just shows his commitment
to this role in the character so i'm
curious if you could talk a little bit
about watching him work because he is so
fully committed to this role what i said
after
working with him on the first film was
that he was the most fearless actor i've
ever worked with
like he just
um has no
filter he he'll do anything he'll try
anything um and he's willing to take
risks you know as as as funny as it
sounds because we're talking about
macgruber and and it's and
and it's absurd in so many senses but i
i was saying in an interview the other
day he's one of the best actors i've
ever worked with he also has this
special ability that like steve carell
has to be completely repugnant in one
moment and very sympathetic and
appealing in the next and i think that's
a real gift and not a lot of people have
that in their toolbox
yeah it was it was insane watching will
work he had his hands in everything you
know
he would be given direction he was
writing i would i would see him on set
literally learning one of those big old
chunks of monologues and then adding
more to that monologue while he was
learning it to get it ready to shoot it
so it was it you you can tell like he he
truly cares and he loves this and um
yeah he's got he's got an incredible
work ethic you know and he's like this
you know sweet person sweet midwestern
guy who just has a very warped and
perverse sense of humor you know and
it's awesome
yes i'm incredibly thankful for will's
sense of humor i really
just so thankful um for both of you guys
how much did they actually tell you
before filming began this is the story
this is what we're thinking about blah
blah blah and how much was it sort of
like you know once you sign on they're
revealing everything
for once you knew you were coming back
i mean for me i read i i've stayed in
touch with these guys through the years
and and we all hope that there was a way
that this could come back to life in
some form so you know i was relatively
involved and i you know i got all eight
episodes and read them immediately um so
they're you know the surprises come on
set when you're when you're shooting or
in between takes with will and kristen
but i you know so
that's that was my journey yeah for me i
think all i
i didn't get the scripts until a little
bit later um but watching the movie was
the biggest like help as they said it
was gonna basically be kind of a sequel
to that movie
um so i was
yeah and our characters are very similar
joe's character in the series is a lot
like piper's arc in in the in the film
um and you know what yorma says to us
us meaning you know the dramatic actors
lawrence and sam and joe myself is to
you know this is real to us this is a
drama this is an action movie to us this
is not a comedy right you can't have a
bunch of people competing to be funny in
a show like mcgruger it's got to be the
humor's got to come from will and
kristen and everybody else makes them
funnier by buying into what's happening
i get oh uh um i've been given the wrap
up signal i'm just going to say i'll
stop there and i'm just going to say i
really hope everyone watches this
because i need more and i just really
want to thank you for making me laugh a
lot awesome
um you guys have a great day thank you
so much you got it
you